- [Instructor] This is a map of East Asia
in the 19th century and you
can already see significant
imperial control by
Western European powers.
You have the British East
India Company in India,
you have the French
initially getting a foothold
in Southeast Vietnam in this orange area
but eventually they will
take over this entire region
that will become one day
Vietnam, Laos, and Cambodia.
You have the Dutch in Indonesia
and you have the Spanish
in the Philippines, but
what we're going to focus on
in this video is the European
and in particular the British
attempt to open up the Chinese
markets to British trade.
China at the time under the
control of the Qing Dynasty.
Well before this period,
Chinese products were in demand
in Europe, in particular,
Chinese porcelain and Chinese silk.
Unfortunate for the Europeans,
the Chinese did not have
a lot of demand for European products
and so you had a balance of trade problem.
These products would be
exported from China into Europe
and you would have hard silver
currency going to China.
And so the imperial powers,
especially the British,
were looking for a solution,
and they eventually found
that opium grown in India, which
is a highly addictive drug,
it's the core constituent
of heroin and morphine,
could be addictive to the
Chinese people and maybe
could help solve this
balance of trade problem,
that silver could then
flow outside of China.
Well you could imagine
the Chinese government,
the Qing Dynasty, had no
interest in opium coming in
to China, it was destructive
to their society,
it was an addictive drug, but
in 1839, the British decide
to force the issue and you
have what will be known
as the First Opium War.
This is a picture of the
Second Battle of Chuenpi,
you see the British vessel
Nemesis, which is actually owned
by a company, the British
East India Company,
destroying Chinese junk ships
and because of this show
of force and this military superiority,
they were able to win the
First Opium War and extract
major concessions from Qing China.
The Chinese had to open
up five ports to trade
with the British, they had to
give the island of Hong Kong
to the British indefinitely
and the British would keep
control of it all the way until
the end of the 20th century.
The Chinese had to pay for
opium that they destroyed,
they had to give
reparations to the British
to pay for the costs of the war.
Now to add insult to injury,
the British were not satisfied
and in 1856, you have
the Second Opium War,
where they tried to extract
even more concessions
from China, after which
opium is legalized,
the whole time opium
flooding into the country
and really undermining the
social fabric of society.
To make matters worse for China,
you have a major civil war
in this time period,
the Taiping Rebellion,
which was started by this sect
of Christianity that viewed
it as their destiny to
overthrow the Qing Dynasty
and this is one of the
most bloody civil wars
that any nation has seen in
history, with over 20 million
people being killed and
historians believe that the Qing
concessions to the British
and then the French
and also the opium that was
undermining Chinese society
was a major contributor to
this long and bloody civil war.
These opium wars are often
cited by Japanese in this
time period as a reason for
their need to industrialize
and become imperial power so
that they don't get unraveled
the same way that Qing
China does by the Europeans.
But to appreciate that
this was even controversial
in Europe.
William Gladstone, as we enter
into the First Opium War,
was a young parliamentarian in Britain
and he will eventually be, at
the end of the 19th century,
a significant British prime minister.
But as the opium war was beginning,
he gave a famous speech in Parliament.
"It is a matter of
certainty that if we stopped
"the exportation of opium
from Bengal and broke up
"the depot at Lintin and
checked the cultivation of it
"in Malwa and put a moral
stigma upon it, that we should
"greatly cripple if not
extinguish the trade in it.
"The great principles of justice
"are involved in this matter.
"You," and he's talking to I
believe the Foreign Minister
who is an aggressive
proponent of the opium wars,
"You will be called upon to
show cause for your present
"intention of making war upon the Chinese.
"They gave us notice to
abandon the contraband trade,
"the trade in opium.
"When they found that we
would not, they had the right
"to drive us from their coasts
on account of our obstinacy
"in persisting in this infamous
and atrocious traffic."
And opium was addictive and
William Gladstone had personal
experience with this, his
sister became addicted to opium.
He went on to say, "I am not
competent to judge how long
"this war may last, but
this I can say, that a war
"more unjust in its origin,
a war more calculated
"in its progress to cover
this country with permanent
"disgrace, I do not know,
and I have not read of."
And a few days later, he wrote,
"I am in dread of the
judgments of god upon England
"for our national iniquity towards China."